make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and you
guys really enjoyed the first part of
silver surfer black you guys really seem
to love that so we're going to continue
this but a couple things because i was
reading you all's comments
a couple things to keep in mind the the
conclusion of the main king and black
story where silver surfer shows up again
to fight the king in black and he's like
all black and different stuff like that
that takes place
after this story this story is when
silver surfer first meets null the
symbiote god so this takes place
long before the events of king and black
even begin um
so as we're kind of jumping back to the
past and then we'll jump back to the
present once we actually pick back up
with king and black the other thing is
you guys constantly ask me where we get
the music from in our videos uh we use
epidemic sound
and and it really just kind of goes from
there right we just sort of pick and
choose based on what we want
um if you guys want i can have my editor
compile a list of the tracks that we use
for epidemic sound and
and post some of those down in the in
the comments or in the description or
something like that but that's where we
get our audio from we're set up
we're really partnered with epidemic
sound and uh use the music that's
provided there
um so in the last video we basically
talked about how silver surfer had kind
of been sucked to this black hole
and basically ended up at some point
along the line where he meets null for
the very first time what this does
is it basically tells us that this
journey the silver surfer went on
through this black hole took him to the
very beginning of all creation right the
very beginning of all things or
seemingly the very beginning of this
universe not really the beginning of the
multiverse or anything but the very
beginnings of this universe now
given the way things are transpiring
here this looks as though he goes all
the way back to the time and encounters
null
before null was defeated by the
celestials and cast back into his own
dimension that looks to be the case
but the important thing here is that
silver surfer facing off against
null that for those of us who are huge
silver server fans we always recognize
the fact that the silver surface power
has waxed and waned a lot over the years
right that's one of the things we talked
about
really in different videos that we've
made that if you go back and you read
the old jim starlin
silver surfer style stories that in
those stories he was
wildly overpowered like he was just
immensely powerful he could time travel
and do all crazy all kinds of crazy
different things over the years his
powers have been decreased a lot
and a lot of that i think was just for
the the the idea of just telling a
particular story but why whatever manner
and whatever means marvel's really
decreased the power of a lot of their
characters over the years that's kind of
a common trend
if you read marvel comics back in the
70s and 80s characters were a lot more
ferocious they were a lot more powerful
but if you read them now they're a lot
weaker than they used to be which is
kind of ironic here
you know look even looking at that and
how powerful the surfer used to be and
looking at this and saying okay so maybe
donnie case is taking the surfer back to
the way his power used to be
in the end it still doesn't matter
because null overpowers him
so quickly this battle takes place in
seconds right it's in mere seconds right
silver surfer goes to launch an attack
against null null sends his living abyss
towards the silver surfer and then
basically ensnares him
just like that it's it's so quick and
then this is actually a
a great display of donnie kate's to show
us how powerful null was
where knoll is when we first really saw
a full-on appearance of knoll
going against somebody who was a space
faring character like the silver surfer
even though the silver silver's powers
have been reduced a lot in comparison to
his older stories he's still immensely
powerful
and i think the you know people know
enough about the surfer to know how
powerful he is even if they don't know
the nuances of what he was capable of
you know each of his feats or abilities
or you know the crazy things he'd done
over the years stuff like that you know
even if people don't necessarily know
those things they know enough to know
he's exceedingly powerful
and so having him face off against noel
who overpowers the surfer
in mere moments is a great display of
knoll's power
and this is what's kind of crazy about
this is that it's not enough to capture
the surfer
he in turn says like i am the god of all
darkness right i am the god of
everything
fly as fast as you can faster than light
it doesn't matter at the end of the day
you are always going to arrive in the
dark right there's no way you can
overcome me there's no way you can get
past me
i am an immutable indestructible force
right and as this happens the silver
surfer who's already weakened from his
trip through the black hole
begins to get even weaker it begins to
get even more tired right consistently
more and more tired now the thing to
understand here is that while the silver
surfer is quite literally
fleeing for his life with him being
taken over by the living abyss the
stance of null is even if you make it
through that black hole when you get to
the other side you'll still be in my
servitude and that's exactly what
happens that was silver surfer being
totally ensnared by null
and then brought back down to where
noel's at that he emerges as what's
called
the void knight he's basically a servant
of null and i'm just gonna say it right
now right
he looks amazing right the artwork in
and of itself is a
is a little more exotic than i'm used to
i'm by no means against it i like the
way that it looks but it's a little more
exotic than i'm used to
but the way silver surfer looks as the
void knight he looks amazing
right he looks absolutely awesome here
and and that's
and it's always one of those things
where i always kind of wondered what
what you know silver surfer would look
like if he was taken over by a symbiote
and this is the answer that we get
right now the crazy thing about this is
that when he is essentially like his
whole board and everything is
restructured by null and he is by all
standards of measurement
a servant of null then immediately this
voice comes out of nowhere and says
herald brace yourself right and just
totally blows off just incinerates the
symbiote the living abyss
directly off a silver surfer and allows
him to return to his normal self and
then he basically tells him like this is
going to hurt and in this moment when
the when when all that symbiote is just
is burned off of him then silver silver
returns back to his normal self right
goes back to silver surfer the way he's
supposed to be and then the herald you
know when silver silver goes back on the
offense to face off against no
this voice says like listen to me harold
like you cannot defeat him you cannot
beat
null if you try you will perish he's
simply just
too far beyond you strength speed
durability his command over the
over the living abyss you do not have
the power to defeat this guy
so run follow my voice right run as fast
as you possibly can
and that's what the silver surfer does
right he books right immediately takes
off this
takes off out of this this world right
this living abyss world that he was
sitting on
the one that's basically moderate or
really controlled by uh by
null and just bolts right just grabs a
surfboard and just
flies as fast as they possibly can and
the indication that's given here
is that he's reaching the speed of light
right that's the indication that's
giving here it's it's not explicitly
stated it's not like and then i fly
at 186 000 1000 miles per second squared
that's not exactly what we're told
instead it's just like he's flying as
fast as he possibly can
and he feels like the light in him you
know that kind of a thing you know like
i feel like i'm moving with the light
that kind of a situation
but noel you know basically kind of
breaks off the chase right he stops for
a moment and then says okay
if that's how it's going to be then
that's how it's going to be now here's
the thing
noel basically tells his his guards you
know stay here keep an eye on this place
and then goes to chase after knowing rat
and on the surface you would think that
because null
is so far beyond silver surfer that
there wouldn't really be any reason for
him to chase him right he's like okay
fine whatever he got away
but the reality is a silver surfer is
immensely powerful he's an exceedingly
powerful character and so it's one of
these things where it's in the interest
of
null to make the silver surfer his own
agent right to take him over
and to bring him into his subservience
so that he could kind of continue his
quest to blink out all the stars and
destroy existence that kind of a thing
right so it really is in his best
interest to do that and that's why he
basically guns after him and as this guy
is is talking to him am i talking to the
silver server jumping back to noren as
this guy's talking to him you know it's
kind of like he's like faster you know
keep going faster and he refers to him
as
nord and this throws a silver surfer off
he's like how do you know who i am and
he's like yes i know you're noran rad
from zinella the silver surfer the
herald of a being called galactus right
the destroyer of worlds but you are
repentant right you are basically death
it weighs on you
and i know what you struggle with i know
that you wish for the sweet release of
death i know that you believe
you deserve it right because of all the
worlds that have died at the hands of
galactus
worlds that you led him to countless
civilizations innocent peoples who are
simply living their existence and then
obliterated by the devourer of worlds
and his desire to satiate his hunger i
know that you have caused all this and i
know that guilt weighs on your mind but
understand
that's not the way it is right that's
the that's the role that was imparted
upon you but you didn't do it out of
malice you didn't do it out of a desire
to watch things die right you did it to
save your world
that was your punishment for saving your
world if you want to call it such a
thing and while you are bringing
galactus to other worlds galactus in and
of himself
is not a a violent being right he's not
a hateful being
he plays a role in the universe right
he's no different than a star going
supernova and wiping out its solar
system or a black hole
moving towards some kind of a galaxy and
sucking everything in it it's just
a force of nature right it's just the
way in which the universe functions and
so ultimately uh
null ends up catching up to the silver
surfer and the silver surfer uses a
portion or really a fragment of his of
his energy
to basically blast out uh you know to
try to blast away from the
from knoll by or really just kind of fly
into him by flying into his dragon and
then incinerating the whole thing but
remember as he does this
he's using his power up that he's
consistently weak and it's one of these
things where it seems to really point to
this idea that the longer he's away from
his current time and in a universe of
light the more of its power cosmic that
he drains the weaker he becomes because
he needs to rest to effectively recharge
it but if he's constantly on the run and
constantly using more power that he can
bring back through recharging then he
just becomes progressively weaker this
and the fact that he's experiencing the
taint of being possessed
by uh by null or being controlled by
null is what starts to turn his body
black
that's what turns him into silver surfer
black to a degree and so basically you
know in the the weaken state that he's
in he grabs his board he says
just follow the follow the voice right
the board basically keeps taking it
right it keeps keeps
sending him in this direction and
finally they arrive to their destination
the being that's been talking to him
this entire time and this being turns
out to be
ego the living planet and the one thing
it says to the silver surfer is
now that you're here and now that we can
combine our forces together
my question to you is do you want to
kill a god with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob corps
if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
you